my work involves using a brain scanner
the one you can see here to measure
people's mental workload while they
perform various tasks so this means that
we can tell when software sucks as well
as when we made it better
humans have limited resources like a
computer processors if you want so let's
draw a good line here and people can
allocate less or more resources to the
task in hand there is two interesting
points here one is close to the maximum
resources and one is close to when we
don't allocate enough resources or we're
doing something repetitive over a period
of time the best example I can think
about is an air traffic controller he's
working very intense for long periods of
times therefore as soon as he's reaching
a close point next to maximum resources
he has he might be prone to mistakes on
the other hand train drivers do a
repetitive task maybe driving hours
waiting for the next train station
therefore they are very close to boredom
obviously the air traffic controller is
doing lots of mental processing keeping
planes in the air or landing planes and
that and that space there is being taken
up underneath the graph and then the
available resources for I don't know
responding to people talking to him and
things are getting less and less and
less that's right and it's always good
to have a balance
so don't work too hard don't work too
little I saw a video recently and I'm
going a bit off-topic of a racing driver
driving along and then trying to do some
text messages and crashing the car
exactly so thinking about I don't know
designing a Sat Nav that is dedicated to
a driver you need to think about that
the driver is already doing a task what
we can do with this technique is to
measure where on the graph the user is
we kind of want to find out more about
the user during interaction and and we
had couple of experiments where we
actually used it in I don't know for
measuring usability of a new system or
comparing two
version of a website and the layout and
and see what impacts has an online users
brain but what we are looking to create
here is a system to tell users the
mental workload in real time so kind of
alerting you for instance if you're
reaching the the high workload level we
were talking about before so maybe on
the graph so maybe you can reallocate
your resources take a break
ask for help we're trying to measure
this effect that it might have on you as
well as if you are not working very hard
then we're trying to communicate this to
you maybe don't so you're not getting
bored and maybe doing something else so
so both ends of that graph are a problem
both ends are a problem and keeping the
right balance would be ideal and now we
should invite max I think we're joined
by max from our wonderful search engine
videos who is involved in this project
as well so tell me what you're gonna do
then what we gonna do is connect his
brain activity data in real-time to the
machine on the right this machine is
going to classify the workload in
real-time it's going to sense when max
is reaching a high workload or what low
workload and then we're going to
communicate the workload we're gonna
give max some feedback using the lamps
so when the workload increases to a high
point the lights will become red
depending on what max is doing he's
getting busier and busier or if he's
getting towards relaxed or boredom we're
gonna change back to white so we can
kind of monitor Max as well as give him
feedback during his interaction with the
computer now I'm gonna ask max to play a
game an air traffic controller game the
game is called airport minus 4 and your
job as a player is to play the role of
an air traffic controller manage the
landings and departure of planes we're
ready we can see Max's brain activity
increasing and decreasing
this is his forehead or what's happening
behind his forehead and the red dots
here mean increased activity so if we
asked max to pause and calm down
and relax you can see that it kind of
goes away or something happens so now if
we start again the experiment I can
connect it to the lights and what do
those lines all mean that you're looking
at there then this is the raw signal
this is normally this technology
measures how much oxygen you have behind
your forehead
how much oxygenated the blood behind
your forehead is however this is just
the road the raw signals and you control
the intensities of each light depending
on the skin color of the participant you
need to have the right level so it
reaches the right depth in your in your
brain we're taking a baseline now that
means we're asking max to relax while we
take an average of his brain activity
right now we connected the lights that
means we can control them from this
machine they will change color when Max
is getting very very busy or his brain
becomes really really active so now can
you start playing the game please
- max already feels that he made a
mistake and something is getting
stressed and stressed and more stressed
and more stressed because he's getting
busier and busier so if I ask max some
questions that's gonna make it even
worse hello can you remind me what perfe
goes through miss the lights are about
five seconds behind what max is going
through this much it takes from the
heart to pump up the blood the brain and
observe the change so let's say max is
getting busy five seconds ago the lights
will turn on red now it's far as going
as well the thing is they were already
wet they come why since she picked the
phone up now try to go back to your task
max hello he's back he's back on the air
traffic controller job he's managing his
own workload apparently no so now what
you have to do is to control the
aircraft that come from the left side
because you became better at the task
they give you more more work to do like
in real life jobs so now you need to
control the aircraft on the small
terminal I'm trying to make max
distracted from the task a little bit
I'm trying to distract him so he's
deoxygenation values reach minus five
which is just crazy I try to relax now
let it go can you pause you can rather
relax until you pause the game this is
typical than typical behavior yeah yeah
you can't because your mind still stays
in the game you can see is trying to to
stay calm but as soon as you can see a
plane approaching a crash he's going
back in the game thanks max for your
time I'm gonna just take it off you know
thank you very much what exactly do you
take away from an experiment like that
well analyzing brainy days
not an easy step it involves a lot of
signal processing we need to clear up
the movement artifacts that makes
potentially dead transforming the raw
data into meaningful oxygenation
information and brain activity
information and you can have a look at
the screen this is the data after it's
been cleared from any kind of movement
artifact and you can see that there is
some interesting moments the signal
going up and down but you can also have
a more understandable if you want
picture at the brain and see which parts
were active during which event using
markers we track interesting events or
with the limit between conditions and
then having something like visual
picture of the brain can give us some
meaningful information so the next step
could be moving towards more wearable
user-friendly devices we're trying we're
trying to use things like smartwatches
like this bit of kit to understand
whether we need or we don't need the
brain scanner really we want something
that people can wear and if we can infer
relativity from something like this then
we might just give up the brain scanner
because everybody is using SmartWatch
these days and fitbit's and other some
sort of equipment so we want is a
measure that will say this result set is
better than that result set and so for
this what we use is an average precision
skocy
and you have to do a lot of matrix
solving to work that one out and that's
the difference in the problem that gets
given to it